-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden spoke to
Britain's King Charles yesterday
for the first time since
Queen Elizabeth's passing.
"I can't believe you waited your
entire life for this lousy job,"
said both of them
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
A possible national railroad
strike was averted today
after 20 hours of talks between
the union's leadership
and labor negotiators
from the railroads.
20 hours of talks
that were very annoying
to everyone else
in the quiet car.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
told reporters
at her press conference
yesterday
that she expects Democrats to
introduce legislation next month
to regulate stock trading
among members of Congress.
Or as she told her stockbroker,
"Sell!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book,
then White House Chief of Staff
John Kelly was so angry
when former President Trump
refused to lower the flag
after Republican Senator
John McCain died
that he told Trump,
"When you die,
the public will come to
your grave and piss on it."
[ Laughter ]
And if you think the line to see
the Queen is long...
[ Laughter ]
According to the same book...
We're just --
This is just book reports.
[ Laughter ]
This is --
Nothing here is political.
We're just reporting on a book.
[ Laughter ]
According to the same book,
the heir to cosmetics company
Estee Lauder
suggested to former
President Trump
that the U.S. buy Greenland.
It would have been
the first time Trump listened
to a cosmetics employee.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump visited
his Virginia golf club this week
as it reportedly
undergoes renovations
ahead of a Saudi-backed
LIV Golf tournament.
He also helped oversee
packing VIP gift bags.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Kansas recently set
a Guinness World Record
for largest collection of
Kansas City Chiefs memorabilia,
with more than 1,000 pieces,
while a man in Cleveland set
a Browns memorabilia record
with two.
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks yesterday announced
a new growth plan
which will add thousands
of new U.S. stores.
Don't believe me?
Look behind you.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty nice living room.
The pilot of a rescue helicopter
that reportedly left behind
a stranded hiker
said that he thought
the man was just waving hi.
[ Laughter ]
Even worse, the hiker
was actually waving
at another helicopter
behind him.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, singer Adele
this week
put her Beverly Hills mansion
up for sale.
She said she has a lot of happy
memories in the house,
which explains why we've never
heard a song about it.
And that...
[ Laughter ]
...was a closer!
That was a monologue, everybody.